or is it here we go 123 players 1764
average rating time handicapped cube
fanatics land game on double the points
no e for over here over here is where
you want to be Knight f3 no matter what
Bishop here this is something we were
going over uh I'm just gonna take that
Queen out is that pong gonna be taken is
it gonna be taken like Castle push this
night around maybe now let me get this
Bishop maybe and then push the night
away and get an f5 f6 maybe I'm being
too optimistic okay this is a good
structure I shouldn't have done that
move pawn push is good very good I'm on
this though when I grab that and get
away with it do this no matter what that
way I have a good retreat with my queen
oh I didn't see that I should be alright
though I have everything covered this
square as well the rook Hampton vade I'm
the seventh and this I'm the second each
floor
oh that was that was missed are they
gonna resign they drop the rook resigned
time back to tournament I got to there's
a bunch of two's though here he is
it's quite good ah I'll watch out for
that though I'll watch out for that this
time watch bishop see yeah I know it's
coming hey hey God is everything covered
it is oh man man imagine if I fall for
it again I'll never recover if I think I
had trouble recovering before it hasn't
even happened and I'm already struggling
I'm playing like it has already happened
I take spine trickiness trickiness watch
out for the trickiness okay I'd like to
get off of this file
pomme pushed another setting up
something it's h2 look at this
Anton if he can't get f2 he's getting h2
or f7 you know what I meant you know
what I meant
Queen trades get out of there get out of
there
is that not gonna take care he might do
that he's going to do that isn't he
clean trade can we got a clean trade
please clean trade just want to hit that
queen around Queen takes mate oh no my
night would end up in a pin clock
situation how we doing are we doing
clock push this pawn he's passed he's
been passed get pushing these passed
pawns my bishops there to watch over it
let's trade could we please trade here
all I want to do ever is trade all I
want to ever do is trade all right let's
go my bishop needs to reroute over here
get out of there all right he needs to
get out of there no no no I should go up
this one that way I could get this pawn
you're gonna get that though anything
anything I need time burners time
burners or the time burners okay hang on
hang on and where are those time burners
anything grab that
check clean is on the scene down on time
down that time back determine oh man I
get so nervous I get so nervous you have
no idea actually you have some idea what
is he talking about give us some credit
here is that what some people are saying
we know we know you mean you know you're
talking about okay this is a good um
she's Grand Prix land and I got a quick
kill I'm still gonna do that yeah let's
do it
this has to be annoying is it annoying
oh hang on my queen is a beast she's a
beast she's a beast she's still a beast
my knight wants to get this pun my queen
is very good she's she's a monster isn't
she this two nights tricky nights
functioning on the dark squares
functioning they're functioning they're
functioning this is leading to mate
isn't it it's got to be made around the
corner here where is that mate this is
made next that's good mate is good mate
is good back to tournament twelve twelve
twelve ten ten twenty five minutes
remaining a lot of time oh no no no no
no no no who knows what that is
who knows name that variation that's the
name that variation right there that is
the Adobe Flash gambit oh that is also a
mouse lip oh I thought I was seeing
things I thought Bishop check was
available I also thought I'd be able to
take that night ah we're gonna have this
ending no I don't even know what I'm
doing I don't even know what I'm doing
I'm dropping her I'm dropping upon I've
already dropped upon already dropped
upon what are you talking about get it
straight
can I get a tricky for concie to my
mother Bishop he's got to come back here
he's not doing that trickiness right
here at sea - that could be a
disaster very quickly disaster hit this
rook it's got to be scary scary town
Bishop before that could be a problem
it's gonna be a problem it's pinned can
I chase this rook away can I chase that
rook away as the plan ooh this could be
dangerous they're chewing up a lot of
time though they're ready to get my
night it was unpinned right there okay
so this is probably isn't gonna end it's
not gonna end is it because of the clock
my best friend because my best friend is
here bishop here no they can't castle
I'm on the bishop yet
bishop here's the threat Oh big trouble
now
big trouble I'll grab this poem and then
played to f3 and then look for a mate on
d1 ooh
unless that move is played so now I'm
looking for trades as usual okay I think
I just wanna know pick up your mind make
up your mind my my mind says to just
make any move because the clock is gonna
just expire doesn't matter doesn't
matter time burners back to tournament
twenty twenty eighteen eighteen
seventeen sixteen okay a lot of time
remaining four games in everybody has
about four or three pawns Center is up
there no I'm not in first anymore why am
I going with a Bodoni
what is with the benoni okay here we go
I got this in is this still the right
idea to do this is that an annoying pin
we're gonna have a bunch of exchanges
exchange exchange right here I want my
knight to get to this d6 square I want
to stop their knight from getting here I
shouldn't have done that move I can't
get in there I can't get in there I
should have done with my queen would
have been a queen trade everybody knows
how much I love that everybody knows Oh
dropping a poem no I'm not there
supporting that advance
they're not the queen is gonna be very
good right here no she is not okay
Queen trade clock situation is about
even I like my rook better or do i right
here they're gonna have a good King
position King position is very good can
I get this in okay am I gonna win that
part I might let's drop back I need some
more oh man that was not good
can I get activity over here activity
activity activity okay my rook is more
active I have more active King - I
grabbed that thing under this I get my
rook here jump over there
oh no I dropped that pond wait could the
King hide he could I shouldn't have done
that so quickly 17 I got this pawn
though ah I need my time burn around
where is my time burner I got this
I got a pawn gonna have a trade got the
rook I want to get rid of him now
I got the rook come over here
six just keep pushing this pine
trickiness they were that was a sneak
attack I can't breathe oh oh I got it oh
oh man oh man be heard
oh man David Blaine mode again that was
David Blaine mode right there where you
hold your breath under that tank in the
tank for seven minutes
that was the seven minute warning right
there oh man yeah why I'd have to be so
close eyes have to be so close I can
block with my bishop
I don't want to do that okay I'll do
that trickiness with the bishop there's
no trickiness we never trade right here
I could give a check or something I'm
not sure there should be seven maybe get
at this point
all right the rook is gonna move and
then the bishops gonna move rook d1 and
then the bishop move is a threat I drop
my queen to c7 maybe put pressure on
this pawn rook c8 all right let's get
out of nonsense I want to do this or
even this this has been there for awhile
okay now I think I do this move next I
think there's some serious problems with
this pin right here so let's take and
I'm gonna take care bunch of times I
have this covered by my knight in Port a
detail very important detail I should
maybe just take this and then get to the
B file with check that was missed I
should've taken a knight maybe that was
better
either way it's still okay right because
I'm getting a rook for a pawn actually
I'm just up a floor ugh here no matter
what I'm pretty sure even with the check
I capture with check now the tricky fork
was in the air now I have it covered
let me just defend here I want to trade
nights that's why I did this so I could
do that
97 kitchen sink kitchen sink get in
kitchen sink right now time burners are
out of time they're out of time back to
tournament forty three forty two forty a
tight tight pack up there eighteen
minutes remaining a lot of time a lot of
time alright this guy get a move yeah he
is gonna move all right I got a quick
kill could I do what Anton did this
might not be too bad of a plan here
maybe maybe can I get a ten attack this
is the idea basically
oh I'm dropping the pond but there
should still be something I would think
ponds gonna drop I don't want to open up
the F file this could still be taken
have the H file though
Bishop takes pawn made on h7 Bishop
takes Bishop I think it could just do
that oh that's a helpmate back to
tournament 56:51 43 42 17 minutes
remaining
c5 no matter what okay let's challenge
this Center what is this the bloomenfeld
gambit Blumenfeld gambit should I have
just taken there I'm not sure really not
sure do this if pawn push I give a check
the knight has to go back okay like this
right here and then I think I'm able to
get this pawn rook up and over I don't
know if these are the best moves oh yeah
it's gonna be it has to be hard but what
about Knight here can I get rid of that
bishop okay I got rid of that fish up
and now I could do this and then look
here or something okay with check this
is not good oh I have this now my bishop
is finally cleared okay next up I want
the Queen's off the board I don't want
to fall for me when I Castle I'm on the
rook time that was jobbed they must have
been in pre-move mode I'm boxing out
that night now going for an attack pawn
push I don't have to castle now I don't
want that pawn to go any further I want
to do pawn push that my queen has some
lateral movement let's take here first
and then do this no matter what
Queen lateral movement
I'm afraid my bishop could back up or
something why'd I even do that I don't
even know I'm running it away scared
right here seven seconds oh I don't have
any time why they all there tell them
their sac in the house they're sacking
the house they're just pre moving their
way to victory no I should be able to
get this four point two seconds is a lot
my queen was just trying to be a knight
right there that's me
the bishop controls the corner square 72
67 66 whoa where did my time go on that
one
I'm not starting with a lot of time why
am I not I know I but that it seemed
like I started with a lot less than that
one okay remove this bishop and then go
for a very Yugoslav like plan with h4 h5
maybe just sack the rook just get that
rook up okay that part could try to be a
giant thorn a giant thorn I think I want
to transition and do this oh that's
gonna be very very dangerous that's
that's game over isn't it
just open stuff up oh yeah that's how
you open stuff up let's try it again
I had a baby step my way to eat for open
stuff up open stuff up bishop check
capture anything I should have maybe
pushed I'm on the Queen
it could take my knight I'm on the Queen
I could still take my knight
that was terrible technique where'd my
piece go where'd my piece go that I had
not too long ago
and now what do I have a stupid night
now I have a stupid night that's what
you get that's what you get it a stupid
night on g7 affiant kettled night yes
everybody loves a Fiat keto tonight oh
what a stupid piece that is what a
stupid piece
wow he's brilliant he's one of the most
brilliant pieces you'll ever see a night
on g7 he is wonderful
oh wait fortunately I had that that was
not calculated my night is still
brilliant if he didn't realize and he's
gone he has left the scene and I believe
the king and Pont endgame is one run
pawn your past and your fast can he be
caught connected passed pawns connected
passed pawns and I could come over here
wow did I really have to come down to
the
I had the the king why'd I even do that
move okay
okay run run run run run run okay
finally I got a queen Wow is this the
best technique in the world or what
over here hang on hang on
time time time time one two three
okay back to tournament that was ugly
ugly ugly if I ever seen that that was
it
ugly technique man ugly up a piece the
Queen was running scared my night was
awesome right there but not when it came
to that ending see how that changed it
was awesome until it came to the ending
then he was out of play ah okay let's do
this this could get into an ending Queen
beats free stuff now we're not having it
okay I have to capture like this I'm
gonna keep that pin block here so
there's no rook move with check this has
to be uncomfortable I'm looking to
actually do some damage now the Queen
could take okay but I get the why am I
not moving Oh
okay can I get this pawn no I want to
hang on to this pot now let's hang on to
him
okay this part is guarded a lot get my
clean doing something I need a flight
Square yet I think this is a good one
with King here
my opponents doing similar but my king
up small improvements Queen trade as
usual remove the block hater in this
case two reasons to go forward with that
clean trade actually it's not so clear
anymore I only have 19 seconds my King
needs to get into a better position it's
not so easy how do I get rid of the King
position okay do this oh they're
dropping that that was a dropped one now
everything is just falling I
of anytime in these games no time okay
pass pawn give a check flush the King
back and then just do this in case
there's an h4 move and I'm there to
protect keep inching my way here
eventually put the king in stalemate and
then deliver mate with my knight that is
the plan okay mate in 1 and then 2 1 and
then 2 no matter what back to tournament
110 105 104 10 minutes remaining okay 10
minutes remaining 110 105 104 10 games
in 11 games 12 games we're all in the
ballpark here TCS press ok more Sicilian
Grand Prix Grand Prix Knight f3 drop
that Bishop all the way back if d5 let's
just do it now no matter what clean a 1
2 H 4 F 5 Bishop h6 I've dropped my
Queen before forgetting that when the
knight moves there's tension between the
Queens they're gonna be Bishop takes
Knight within it take on that square I
think that'd be kind of suicidal to give
up that dark square Bishop so now the
plan is Knight g5 like g5 is the big
plan I'm sacking a couple parts to do
this but there we go the Queen I almost
have most missed it again Bishop takes
and then Queen takes h7 is the plan and
I can remove a knight that tries to
defend against h7 this is guarded so I
want to maybe take and then take this
Bishop or I can even take this pawn
maybe I should have done that let's do
it now my knight is a monster right
there he has to go this pawn is also
pinned I could take this rook but then I
drop my knight no I don't want to do
that I'm not sure what I'm doing there's
got to be something good here let's drop
up drop all the way back takes here and
then takes here
I think that works or even that this
this is falling isn't it
that's definitely falling let's take
this first clean check is leading to
mate check and then mate next no it's
not me oh no I made on f7 it might in my
phone for something oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh I I have enough time I
thought it was my clock that was taking
like that just defend okay good
anything anything at all Oh for a second
I thought I was down to five seconds it
was my opponent's clock I'm down 145 145
131 130 and to catch that guy
Bigfoot gotta play against Bigfoot okay
oh man how did how did I drop back oh
why did I do that move okay I have a
center push forward even further I want
to get at h2
alright can I make this work these ponds
rolling get these ponds go and create
something against the king fast
something fast is what I'm looking for
why did I close that up okay grab that I
grab that limb and jump into here if
that pond pushes I jump in there any
checks I could block with my light
square bishop or just even move my king
I get here what am i doing okay I really
just want that King to move how do I get
at that King that knight move I could
get that be PI and I hope it's being
defended Bishop takes pawn though I want
to be able to take that Bishop and then
get me
let's come over here King g7 21 seconds
get rid of that night mmm I'm gonna take
that pine it's crazy if they do that I
can't I can't break through that pond is
falling I'm floundering here I don't
know they drop tonight they drop that
night in resign
look here no matter what that wasn't a
good one you get here for mate mate
threat made threat that's me oh man 150
168 168 165 151 150 150
not getting any quick wins ah how can
you get a quick win with the e3 to start
how could you get a quick win with that
start can I get it have seven really
quick no man I'm on this pawn pin that
night and get it this Bishop just plays
here it's not playing there this could
this could fall apart fast I'm on this
square as well oh I'm on f7
I want to keep my knight around I want
to get a fork on f7 take this pawn and
then there's working possibilities I
could take that rook and then land a
fork we're in an endgame but okay it's
winning but I'm not able to win click
here why wasn't that taken
should I have castle two misdirection
pawn push Bishop to h3 let's come over
here is that gonna be hit just watch out
for it pawn push in the center can I
break open the center bishop here what's
this Knight up to I'm hitting the rook
then I could play here something open up
the file that the king is on alright can
I give this King some problems let's do
this I'm not sure why I'm not sure why
okay get rid of that rook oh I should
have given check first
Bishop blocks oh hang on just give me
that Bishop 12 seconds from my opponent
they're gonna resign they resigned back
to tournament 185 175 174 171 179 4
minutes remaining
where's a quick win I need one quick win
to just get back up there two more games
I could maybe be getting in I didn't
just drop something there did I all
right I get these pawns going I just
dropped upon okay I'll take with my
knight so I'm guarding this that was bad
that was bad okay let's defend this and
then do what man queen trade oh man I'm
getting absolutely no quick wins how do
I get a quick win from this okay defend
over here if Knight might be I jump in
here and defend
my nights ready to get kicked away I
like that mover a lot a four is very
nice this night can read now rely upon
that b5 square for some time let me
Castle and defend I want to get rid of
this rook very soon but it's kind of
tough I don't want to open up that
diagonal Bishop e7 and then Bishop f6 if
possible I might have to do this if the
knight moves yep okay so let me make
sure that that Bishop doesn't get too
active and now let me get my King in a
better position although we could have a
back and forth King King c6 King a7
stuff but no not now I need to get my
knight doing something else he's stupid
he's a stupid night where does he think
he's going let's get out of pins for one
thing all right my knight is heading for
that square is that moving to be played
okay King Knight right here is where I
should be going that's gonna now be the
idea I want to overtake this square so I
can maybe get this pawn advance in I
think my opponent is also struggling to
come up with something over here I have
a good King position okay now we have
this bunch of exchanges and just Bishop
here next they have rook activity
there's no time though it does not
matter anything no time anything at all
whoa don't get mated whatever you do
back to tournament 190 whoa oh man
eighteen games there's only a minute 38
there's only a minute 38 I'm not even in
top three land how do you get 18 games
in that's a lot of games um pawn push no
matter what I need a quick kill I
definitely need a quick kill here giving
me stuff I get a quick killing
on the Queen kick that night away okay
smash through at this point that just
feels right to do this I'm on the Queen
I'm on the Queen take care take care
anything are they gonna resign 49
seconds I want to be able to force I
want to be able to get this win can't
let any if 30 is 35 seconds let's check
uh clock clock clock that doesn't even
do anything that doesn't even do
anything okay
that does
one two they're gonna Nonna fry me are
they gonna know how to fry me no they
didn't back to chairman oh it didn't
matter I got that win but that's it the
tournament's complete up thanks for
playing whoa 19 18 17 20 games twenty
games is even a lot fifteen eighteen
sixteen sixteen to fifty four to twenty
six to twenty five to fifteen to ten I
only had 15 games in aa did not get an I
didn't get any quick wins good games ah
that one game that I had that piece up
that was my own fault there should have
been a quicker killing that when I would
have thought ah